will a candidate's rage keep voters
engaged a new study finds that
politicians could boost supporters
motivation
by losing their temper researchers
showed voters from across the political
spectrum fake news stories
from phony candidates which sounds an
awful lot like cnn's coverage of joe
biden
am i right participants reported that a
candidate
that showed anger increased the
likelihood that they'd attend rallies or
vote on election day
researchers warned that making
supporters angry works in the short term
but has the negative long-term
consequences of making everyone hate
each other
perhaps claiming voter id laws are the
worst thing since the civil war
could lead to a civil war which is
awesome because i love
sequels emily you often curse around the
office your reputation is that you are
just mean to everybody
beneath you uh uh so has that helped you
in your success fake news while we're on
the subject of sequels i'm
really excited for top gun too okay so
here's the
the thing that stood out to me about
this whole study
is that it it also said that people
started to mirror the anger they saw in
these politicians and that political
angry rhetoric and political fear
started to spread which is what we know
and spread easily
and so i feel like this is exactly what
we talk about all the time which is that
the media stokes the fire they in fact
they are the incendiary they're the
beginning of it they're the spark
that they then continue to amplify and
so i get that the main point is
it will drive to voter gains or
candidate gains on voting day
but in the interim it's making a whole
lot of us pretty miserable
amen tyrus yeah well
i i agree everything that emily said
except uh she's never really cussed at
me it's usually like a soft mumble
and i go like what was that she's like
i'm working nothing um
what of course we like angry politicians
because everything we see on the media
is angry and it's either you're either
on their side or you're a horrible
racist misogynistic person
so politicians they watch the news they
see what's going on and then
whatever is in their lane if i'm a
democrat and i want to defund the police
i'm calm mad as hell about what's
happening with this
to their base to stir everyone up but be
as mad as i am
but it works for a while but then they
don't ever want to deal with the media
and politicians never have to deal with
the consequences
of telling real people who are living in
those consequences
how angry they should be and they never
ever have a solution there's no
consequences for
politicians and and new news media and
that's why i was like
we need to start making them responsible
qualified immunity
should not go to politicians they should
be responsible for the
they put out on us so should maybe news
networks that i agree 100
i mean cnn ran four years on rage real
rage fake rage whatever rage it was good
for their ratings now that they don't
have the rage
i mean that we know where their ratings
are right and then somebody burns
because you're telling them that there's
nothing they can do there's no hope and
instead of saying
wow i think we went too far it's nothing
to see here
everything's fine i was surprised about
this study though because it was
conducted in minnesota
uh where i've yet to meet an angry
person
they're just all passive-aggressive so
oh
he's not that nice
that's the resp that was the angry
response right i will say it does come
full circle though because
barack obama love him or hate him he ran
on an aspirational message
right there is a cycle when that comes
back also uh i was
uh trump didn't make you angry he made
you laugh at the people who are angry
which they have it's the
it's the happy warrior that i think we
all like often like joe
joe i gather being cool sexy and smooth
is a more persuasive tactic i find that
works in the
wrong long run greg uh
i think revenge is like cold pizza it's
best served cold
uh i'm gonna say cold pizza
but yeah i don't look at people who
disagree with me as necessarily bad
people i just think that they're stupid
people that i have to persuade